CONSISTENTLY GONE OUT.
>> TRACE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU,
NOT HERE WITH REACTION, TRUMPS
FORMER ATTORNEY, THE GUY THAT
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR BRINGING THE
MURDER DOWNGRADE FROM ABOUT 2500
YEARS TO WAIT ON UNDER 500,
REMEMBER ALMOST EVERY DAY YOU
WERE CALLED A RACIST.
YOU SAVED THOUGHT THOUSANDS OF
LIES EVERY YEAR WHAT YOU WERE
MARRIED.
HERE WE HAVE --
NO COP IS GOING TO WANT TO SAVE
A LIFE IF THIS IS ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE.
>> WELCOME OF THIS IS VERY, VERY
DANGEROUS AND IT'S THE RESULT OF
YEARS AND YEARS BY THIS TOTALLY
INCOMPETENT MAYOR OF ANTIPOLICE
RHETORIC GOING WAY BACK TO WHEN
HE WAS FIRST IN OFFICE AND A GUY
CAME FROM BALTIMORE AND
ASSASSINATED OFFICES, RAMOS
ASSASSINATED HIM IN A CAR.
AFTER HE HAD MADE SOME VERY,
VERY STARLESS COMMENTS ABOUT THE
NYPD, THE NYPD IS THE GREATEST
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE
WORLD, SEAN.
IT IS NOT IN ALL WAY POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT IS 60% NOTHING.
IT IS WHITE, BLACK, ASIAN, BUT
THE POLICE OFFICERS YOU SEE
BEING ASSAULTED WITHOUT WATER IS
AN ASIAN POLICE OFFICER, ROOKIE.
THE POOR KID IS JUST OUT OF THE
ECONOMY AND WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED
TO DO?
>> Sean: I KNOW WHAT I WOULD
DUPE YOU AND I WOULD TURN AROUND
AND FIGHT BACK.
>> WELL, I HAD AT LEAST, YOU
KNOW I RUN A SECURITY BUSINESS.
I WORK WITH A LOT OF POLICE
OFFICERS, FBI AGENTS, I MUST
HAVE HAD 30 PHONE CALLS AND 30
PEOPLE THAT CAME UP TO ME,
POLICE OFFICERS, AND FBI AGENTS
AND FEDERAL AGENTS WHO SAID THEY
UNDERSTOOD WITH THIS KID WAS
GOING THROUGH.
IF YOU ARE ON THE JOB, FIVE, SIX
YEARS, TAKING A PERSON, YOU
WOULD'VE ARRESTED HIM.
THIS KID IS ON PROBATION.
HE KNOWS THE MAYOR WILL TURN ON
HIM.
I DON'T CARE WHAT de BLASIO IS
SAYING NOW.
HE HAS TURNED ON THE COPS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
WE WANT SO NOW HE IS GOING TO BE
ASSAULTED AS A POLICE OFFICER?
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE NOW TELLING
HIM?
STICKLEY, AND WHERE IS SCHUMER,
AOC, OUR DEMOCRATIC
REPRESENTATIVES IN CONGRESS,
WHERE ARE THEY STANDING ON THE
POLICE?
NO PLACE WHERE THEY ARE HIDING.
UNBELIEVABLE.
HOW INTERESTING IT FOR THE
POLICE.
>> Sean: THEY CAN'T DO THIS TO
CAUSE.
NO COP IS GOING TO WANT TO SAVE
THEIR LIFE IF THIS CONTINUES.
>> THIS GOES BACK TO OBAMA.
HE GOES BACK TO HILLARY CLINTON.
NOT ALLOWING UNISON A POLICE
OFFICERS AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION.
THEY ARE DISGRACEFUL AND THE
GENTLEMAN THAT USE OUR RIGHT
BEFORE ME IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS LEADS TO VERY SERIOUS CRIM
CRIME.
DEPUTY POLICE COMMISSIONER OR
COME OFFICER TODAY HOW THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THERE ARE RANDOM SHOOTINGS GOING
ON IN NEW YORK NOW.
PEOPLE BEING KILLED AND SHOT BY
RANDOM BULLETS.
I INHERITED THAT AND I STOPPED
IT AND BLOOMBERG KEPT IT THAT
WAY.
AND, I CAN EVEN SAY WHAT I WILL
CALL THEM.
THIS MAYOR IS A DISGRACE.
AND I DON'T CARE IF HE'S SAYING
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU
ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN.
YOU ENCOURAGED IT, MY FRIEND.
>> Sean: WELL, LOOK, LET ME
JUST ASK YOU A QUESTION
QUESTION.
I WANT THE REAL RUSSIAN STORY
TOLD BY REPUBLICANS IN THESE
COMMITTEES.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ALL THAT.
>> THE REAL RUSSIAN STORY IS
THAT MUELLER IS A COMPLETE
INCOMPETENT AND HE HAD A
COMPLETELY DISGRACEFUL SET OF
PROSECUTORS INCLUDING WISEMAN
WHO HAS BEEN PROVEN TO HAVE
BASICALLY GOTTEN PRETTY CLOSE TO
PERJURY AT LEAST THREE TIMES,
INCLUDING TRYING TO GET A
UKRAINIAN OLIGARCH TO GIVE FALSE
TESTIMONY AND HE HAS BEEN
BASICALLY EXPOSED BY THE GUY'S
LAWYERS AND JOHN SOLOMON'S
COLUMN YESTERDAY.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOT TO COME OUT
HERE WITH SCOTT'S COME OUT IS,
THIS WAS A PLOTS.
IT WAS A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
PLOT THAT WAS CONCEIVED IN
WASHINGTON AND PLAYED OUT BY
UKRAINE, U.K., AUSTRALIA, ITALY,
THEY ALL COOPERATED TO FRAME
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WAS A COUP.
IT WAS AN ATTEMPT TO STOP THEM
AND THEN TO TAKE HIM OUT OF
OFFICE.
IT'S WHAT WE CALL A FRAME UP AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT'S
DISGRACEFUL AND MUELLER EITHER
KNEW ABOUT IT OR HE IS SO
INCOMPETENT HE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
IT WHICH MAY BE IS EVEN WORSE.
STU AND MR. MAYOR, WE BE
WATCHING.